Пісня з берегів Дніпра звучить у місті на Рейні.
Через війну киянин Олег Яновицький виїхав до Бонна,
і часто співає на центральній площі.
Чоловік каже: йому приємно продовжувати справу бременських музикантів на батьківщині Бетховена.
Співав досить довго у хорах, потім у професійних хорах співав.
Але в останні роки я повернувся до серйозних занять вокалом і ось коли настав уже пенсійний вік,
вирішив кардинально змінити своє життя та почати співати на вулиці.
Мені був дуже цікавим цей досвід Бременських музикантів.
До війни Олега Яновицького можна було почути на вулицях Києва - йому подобалася вулична музика.
Нині в центрі Бонна чоловік виконує світову класику -
від "Серенади" Франца Шуберта до пісень Елвіса Преслі й Френка Сінатри.
Українські ж пісні, каже Олег, публіка сприймає особливо тепло.
У мене багато разів було таке: людина проходить повз мене,
чує українську пісню, посміхається і зупиняється.
Думаю, українець, мабуть, бо українців тут багато.
Я доспівую, питаю: "- Ви з України? - Ні!". Виявляється німці, просто їм сподобалося, от і слухають.
Глибокий голос Олега помітили й професійні музиканти.
Йому запропонували прийти на прослуховування до Боннської опери.
Він заспівав арію Дона Базіліо із "Севільського цирульника" російською мовою.
Я вперше почув її російською і сказав, що він має гарний український бас.
У результаті Олега прийняли до театрального хору.
Нині він бере участь у постановці опери "Азраїл" Альберто Франкетті -
твору, який Боннська опера відновила після майже ста років забуття.
Опера на сцені з жовтня минулого року.
Олег - фізик-теоретик за освітою, але в Німеччині йому вдалося реалізувати свою давню мрію -
зробити музику другою професією.
Математика, фізика - це основне.
Я люблю викладання фізики та математики дітям.
Але музика - це те, чим я можу тут займатися, не знаючи досконально мови.
І мені випала така нагода.
Я потрапив до опери, де ми зараз з вами розмовляємо.
Це наша хорова зала.
Потрапити з вулиці до хору такого рівня практично неможливо.
Але хормейстер каже, що Олег мав чудову підготовку й неймовірну цілеспрямованість -
партії він вивчив дуже швидко.
Усі колеги погодилися прийняти Олега до нашого хору.
І йому все вдалося, нині він навіть братиме участь у другій опері, швидше за все, у "Сибіру" Умберто Джордано,
оскільки вона добре вписується в тему Росії.
Крім Боннської опери Олег співає також у камерному хорі Боннського університету.
А також продовжує викладати дистанційно.
Каже, що усе це - непоганий додаток до пенсії,
й дозволяє йому не залежати від соцвиплат для біженців від німецької держави.
Звісно, мене дуже тягне додому, я б вже поїхав додому, але роботи вдома особливо нема.
А те, що я можу робити тут, тобто навчати дітей фізики й математики онлайн і співати, я можу тут.
І навіть з більшим задоволенням, оскільки це опера, ніж вдома.
Водночас Олег продовжує співати на вулиці.
Каже: йому важливо зберігати безпосередній контакт із публікою.
До того ж це дозволяє збирати кошти на допомогу Україні.